hey 42 here as an englishman i was
raised to speak well english and over
the years i've developed a special
fondness for my mother tongue i love the
odd idioms with phrases like all mouth
and no trousers a different kettle of
fish and bubs your uncle even though my
uncle's name is actually derek
i also love the bizarre words you find
buried away in the english lexicon like
death and straight an utterly useless
word that's incredibly hard to get into
a sentence
unless you happen to be throwing someone
out of a window
or how about bum fiddle which is a
musical instrument not something you
like to do in dark rooms on a saturday
night
then there's robinson aid
it sounds like something you might drink
when you've got fierce diarrhoea but
it's actually a genre of fiction about
people getting marooned on desert
islands
as you might have guessed the word was
introduced to describe an entirely new
genre of literature spawned by a single
story the tale of robinson crusoe
written by daniel defoe
the book became an instant classic when
it was first published over 300 years
ago and it's often touted as the first
novel in english literature but the
release actually caused a bit of
confusion at the time because the title
page contained the words written by
himself
as a result many people thought it was a
true story which it isn't
or at least not exactly
because whilst robinson crusoe is indeed
a work of fiction
it turns out it was heavily influenced
by the incredible survival story of a
real man
now if you love traveling then you'll
love the fastest and easiest vpn surf
shark did you know surf shark helps you
to avoid price discrimination based on
your location
so you can save money on plane tickets
and car rentals whilst travelling
surfshark runs on any device anywhere
and it's packed full of features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
ip and dns leak protection an internet
kill switch if your vpn drops out and 24
7 customer support personally i use
surfshock to watch netflix content from
other countries such as the us that's
usually blocked here in the uk it's so
easy all i have to do is switch over my
location settings and there i have it
access to all my favorite programs
surfshark maintains a strict no logs
policy and their network of 3200 servers
in over 95 countries runs 100 on ram so
they couldn't log your data even if they
wanted to by using the code 42 you'll
benefit from an 83 percent discount plus
three extra months for free
all you have to do is click the special
link in the description below don't miss
out
and thanks to surfshark for sponsoring
this video
alexander selkirk was born in 1676 in
lower largo scotland
as these were the days before tv and
condoms he was one of seven brothers and
the youngest two so to use another
colourful english expression he sucked
behind teat that may be why as a lad he
was a bit of a loose cannon a lower
largo church record from 1693 shows he
was once summoned to a meeting with the
town elders for indecent conduct in
church
just what exactly counted as indecent
conduct in the mid 17th century
is anyone's guess
but it must have been something pretty
bad because rather than face the justice
of the elders
selkirk sailed out into the stormy
waters of the north sea and didn't
return to his hometown for a full eight
years
not that he seems to have learnt all
that much whilst he was away
selkirk had hardly been home five
minutes before he found himself in
trouble again with the local parish this
time for the much less ambiguous crime
of assaulting his family
the story goes he was somehow pranked
into drinking salt water from a can
a ruse that apparently went down like a
fart and a lift because he responded by
giving the brother he was responsible a
thorough beating
when another of his brothers stepped in
to break things up selkirk beat him up
too
then his father and finally
his brother's wife
at this point it's fair to say it had
become clear selkirk wasn't really cut
out for life in lower largo where there
was a distinct lack of jobs requiring
experience in indecent conduct and
domestic violence but luckily he found
his calling in the form of privateering
basically piracy that had been legalized
by the british government
for all his faults he was said to be an
excellent sailor and navigator
and in 1703 he used those skills to
secure himself a place as second in
command aboard an english ship called
cinco ports
at the time spain and france were pitted
against their so-called grand alliance
of england the dutch republic and the
holy roman empire in the war of the
spanish succession
sinkaport was one of the many vessels
tasked with harassing spanish and french
ships and settlements off the coast of
south america
so the crew had the full backing of the
crown but the voyage was not without
problems the food was infested with
cockroaches and rats
infectious disease ripped through the
crew including dysentery a condition
which causes diarrhea so bad not even
robinson aide can cure it
and the lack of vitamin c in the sailor
diets led to an outbreak of scurvy which
claimed multiple lives including that of
the ship's captain charles pickering
pickering was replaced by 21 year old
lieutenant thomas stradling an upper
class sort he was unpopular with the
crew and absolutely despised by our man
alexander selkirk
the two men spent most of their time in
open conflict and in october 1704 things
came to a head
[Music]
the sinkaport was anchored off what are
today known as the juan fernandez
islands an archipelago about 650
kilometers off the coast of chile
quite literally in the middle of nowhere
and the ship's crew were getting some
much-needed r r between plundering
sessions
but selkirk wasn't happy to simply put
his feet up the sinkaport was leaking
badly and possibly infested with
woodworm
as far as selkirk was concerned the ship
was hardly seaworthy a point he made
very clear to his new captain but
straddling was having none of it and
soon enough the two men were engaged in
a blazing round
as is often the case during particularly
spirited arguments selkirk said
something in the heat of the moment
he would quickly come to regret he
claimed the sinkaport was in such poor
condition he'd rather stay on juan
fernandez than risk spending another
single day on the ship out in the open
ocean
obviously this bold statement was
nothing more than an idle threat
designed to show straddling just how
desperately the ship needed repairs
but the sinkaport's captain immediately
called selkirk's bluff
full of self-righteous indignation
selkirk was forced to leave the ship
when he realized no one was going to be
joining him in his rebellion against
straddling he apparently splashed out
into the shallows and pegged to be let
back on board
it didn't help
straddling may have been young but he
wasn't a fool he knew his crew could
mutiny at any moment
leaving selkirk behind not only silenced
one of the loudest dissenting voices
it also made a very clear statement
this new captain was not a man to be
trifled with
and so the singapores headed out back
into the sea
one man lighter
as an aside selkirk's predictions of
unseaworthiness turned out to be pretty
spot-on the sinkaports did eventually go
down off the coast of what is now
colombia many drowned but straddling and
a few of his men survived
only to be captured and imprisoned by
the spanish
selkirk didn't know it but he was
actually the lucky one
because despite being completely alone
on a very remote island
at least he had a musket a knife a pot
to cook with some bedding tobacco
clothes and a copy of the bible
it was marginally better than being
locked in a spanish prison and a lot
better than being dead to begin with
selkirk lived on the beach surviving on
a diet of lobsters because eating fish
gave him the trots
as you'd expect he spent a lot of time
alone contemplating his existence
which on the whole was pretty miserable
even the arrival of multitudes of horny
sea lions coming ashore for mating
season couldn't improve selkirk's stormy
mood
and if the sound of shagging marine life
can't cheer you up
nothing can
selkirk decided to relocate his camp
inland and it was there that things
finally took a positive turn selkirk
built himself two sturdy huts out of
wood from local pepper trees
one he used for sleeping and the other
for cooking
goats left behind by previous visiting
sailors presented him with a decent
protein supply and he found various
vegetables that could be spiced up a bit
with the local peppercorns
not that life was entirely rosy along
with the goats over the years visiting
ships had blessed the island with a
fairly serious rat infestation
and the little furry nightmares would
attack selkirk as he slept
ever resourceful the maroon sailor
solved this little problem by taming
some of the island's feral cats
more cast aways from visiting ships
earning himself some nocturnal security
[Music]
in the early days selkirk hunted the
island's plentiful goats with his musket
but it wasn't long before his small
supply of ammunition ran out
at that point he was forced to catch his
dinner with his bare hands literally
chasing the animals down on foot through
the island's thick undergrowth the goats
also provided selkirk with a source of
clothing when the outfit he was marooned
in began to fall apart as to son of a
tanner he was able to fashion
rudimentary goat leather clothes by
stitching the hides together using an
old scavenged nail in place of a needle
during the course of selkirk's exile two
ships visited the island
unfortunately both were full of
spaniards who would only have rescued
selkirk in order to kill him or throw
him in prison
for the most part selkirk tried to stay
out of sight but he was spotted on one
occasion and the crew of one of the
ships spent a good while trying to catch
him
in truth they never really had a chance
selkirk had gone full native by this
point he knew the island like the back
of his hand and he moved through the
thick underbrush with the speed and
agility that can only come from years of
chasing goats
in the end the men gave up and simply
sailed away
as the years rolled by selkirk continued
to hone his survival instincts
and by the time he was eventually
rescued he was perfectly adapted to
island life
that day was the 2nd of february
when a ship belonging to an english
privateer woods rogers anchored offshore
selkirk's prayers had been answered but
according to rogers those prayers would
only have been comprehensible to god
himself or perhaps more likely the holy
goat
in the four years and four months since
he first set foot on the island selkirk
had partially lost the ability to speak
other than that he was reportedly in
great shape and not badly dressed for a
man whose entire wardrobe was made out
of cloven-hoofed animals selkirk
exhibited his skills by catching two or
three goats a day for his undernourished
and scurvy ridden rescuers ultimately
helping to nurse them back to health and
equipping them for a return to the high
seas
now after four odd years spent with
horned goats and horny sea lions you may
assume selkirk was eager to put his
maritime career behind him but once
aboard the duke rogers ship
the skipper made him second mate and
navigator
some serious swashbuckling tales
followed including the capture of a
galleon carrying a massive hall of
treasure
things went so well that it was two for
years
before selkirk finally arrived back in
london
eight years older and 800 quid richer
than the day he'd left
that's well over a hundred grand in
today's money
back on british soil selkirk found he'd
become a minor celebrity and he enjoyed
a life of moderate wealth free dinners
and bottomless pints as he toured the
country's pubs telling his tale
and it seems he was even starting to
feel a bit more like his old self
because he was soon charged with assault
again
this time escaping justice by eloping
with alas from lower largo the two never
married though old selkirk was always a
sailor at heart and in his forties he
enlisted in the royal navy which was his
full-time occupation when daniel defoe
published the life and surprising
adventures of robinson crusoe in 1719
the novel's title illustration showed a
solitary barefoot map in goatskins
standing alone on the shore of an island
to those familiar with selkirk's story
the influence on defoe's creation would
have been abundantly clear
alexander selkirk died two years after
the fictional character of robinson
crusoe entered the world he was serving
as an officer on a british naval vessel
off the coast of africa when he
contracted yellow fever and passed away
in december
1721. he was buried at sea in a simple
ceremony which basically means he was
thrown overboard
i can't help but think that perhaps
something a little more significant
would have been more appropriate
for a man who survived half a decade
alone on a desert island and inspired
one of the most important works in
english literature
thanks for watching